welcome to the premium mentors podcast
my name is hisham azuz
today i'm very excited to be joined by
melissa
horton who is the director of the uk
permanent division for an agency called
tech melissa has worked within eight
years
and in that time progressed from
consultant all the way to director
status
she's now uh responsible for a team of
18 people
and that do over roughly 1.5 million
turnover melissa thank you for uh
joining me
thank you for having me very excited to
be here
amazing well where i want to start is
in your opinion what characteristics and
traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
i could probably list off a lot if i'm
honest but i'll try and keep it brief
so i would say the top one for me would
be a winning mindset
okay talk to me what do you mean by that
someone that when a bad thing happens or
something happens that they can't
control they want to find a solution to
win
they don't dwell on it they're not
negative a lot around positivity i guess
with their minds that is so crucial to
to being successful in recruitment
how do you find out or look for that in
an interview
i would ask them to talk to me about how
they deal
how they've dealt with in the past
situations where
things haven't gone their way how
they've reacted to it giving me tangible
examples of
how they've used their mindset to bounce
back
um okay do you think that
out of interest on this because i find
it so interesting
do you think that winning mindset can be
taught
yes in a way but not
totally i think it does need to be
something that's inside you
i've helped people get there along the
way
but it does need to be something that's
inside them i think from the beginning
yeah okay yeah interesting um
so look what what i'm really excited to
do on this episode
um mel and as i was sharing before we
started one of the most
common goals that recruiters have shared
with me is
they want to get to that director's
status within their company
so um you recently got a promotion right
to director opponent division before
that is an associate director
yeah so what what i'm really excited to
do is unpack the last sort of
eight years right so just for context
just to help us out
so from what i can see just got a
promotion
right in in october before that was
around sort of two years you as a
associate director
yeah and just helped me out obviously
you joined oscar around 2012
so like what was the journey before like
just help me out with like
start as a resource a consultant then
was it manager like what was the
route and then we'll start unpacking it
yeah so i started as a trainee
so as a resourcer um it was my first job
in recruitment
straight out of university i did drama
at university
so completely different and but i did
work in telesales part-time so i had a
little bit of sales experience but
nothing in regards to recruitment so
joined as a trainee
and then moved into being a consultant
after about 11 months so it was quite a
long
training period and i learned a lot in
that year
okay and then after that how long was
you then the consultant
so after that i was a consultant for
around two years
and then moved into being a senior
consultant
took on my first trainee and then after
about
another year moved into being a lead
consultant
and then progressed again to managing
consultant
then to head of practice and then to
associate director
and um and then just help me out as our
final thing
throughout that whole period have you
always built
yes really okay still but it's okay so
you
there wasn't a point where you were
hands off because that's good for me
tonight okay
yeah so let's start at the beginning of
this then mel
how how how would you describe your
first year as a trainee
at oscar just talk to us how was that
people talk about the recruitment roller
coaster and it was definitely that
i was i guess quite naive um
when i first started out i believed what
all clients and candidates said to me
and i guess if i got along with them
well i didn't really
um didn't really think they would lie to
me or
like that was quite a learning curve and
so it was a lot about being brave
and i guess walking away sometimes from
situations from from jobs that aren't
going anywhere and
i wasted a lot of time initially um on
candidates and clients that were never
going to make me any money
so yeah it was definitely a learning
curve and i was only
21 when i started so my confidence
wasn't
where it is now and so that took me a
while to
to build that up as well yeah i think at
the beginning
we will have we will remember yeah
having the perfect candidate
yeah or like no no honestly they no
they're perfect
they told me this they told me that
right it's definitely something you've
learned
yeah there no no yeah so okay
interesting yeah what what advice did
you
receive early on that really helped you
the advice that i received um would be
to spend my time wisely
as much as um someone will
you'll get along well with somebody and
they'll tell you all the right things
it might not be worth your while
spending all that time
working on something that's never going
to go anywhere
and i guess the advice also is to just
work as hard as you possibly can
because it is true that your first year
in recruitment is is one of the hardest
so if you put 110 into it
it will pay off and it did do in the
long run but not straight away
okay cool so um
going into then consultant yeah and then
went to consultant so
um what what made you what
what did make you stick it out out of
interest
why didn't you quit why why did you
carry on oh
good question um i think for me a lot of
people in recruitment do
compare themselves to others around them
and people that you start with at the
same time
and i guess i was i was i was doing that
but
i didn't really want to fully focus on
them i knew inside me that
i could do it and i was just very
determined to
not prove people wrong but do you know
what i mean by saying that
if yeah perhaps you're not the most
confident person but you know that you
can be
so i wanted to really push myself every
single day to get there
i like that so i think look i think in
in today's day and age i think instagram
is a perfect place to compare yourself
and feel inferior right so i think
i i like the way that you've looked at
that it's like yes i did sort of compare
myself to other people who i started the
same time with
but i didn't i made sure that the main
where
most my energy went was myself yeah so
so i think that's just an important
thing isn't it it's like yes it's good
to compare have be competitive but
make sure that your energy is on
yourself and your own development
absolutely and people learn at different
paces as well
um it did take me a while to get good at
this job but
i've been able to progress and the
people that i started with back then
aren't here now even though they
progress quicker than me initially
interesting so you then how long was
your consultant for
before i went to managing people yeah um
two years two years so
what were those two years like did you
become pretty good biller
and and also just for context
have you always worked so your permanent
division i was going to say have you
always been contract but that was that
would be wrong
so yeah obviously have you always done
perm or always done perm
yes yeah so i i was a trainee for 11
months
um so when i went into being a
consultant i was prepared quite well
for it and i did i did bill um
quite well initially it was up and down
and when i first went
consultant i think my first three months
i did
20 grand for each of those months and
then i had a blank
so it was dealing with those ups and
downs initially
but yeah it took me a while to remit to
get consistent
okay so let's just talk about that for a
sec
yeah so from what i gathered on linkedin
so like you do the
obviously the tech market and you do it
in sort of northern regions it seems
like
yes yes yeah north west yeah
northwest so what did you have to get
really good at that enables you to stand
out in the crowd or
have a chance because for me tech
recruitment is the most crowded place
like yeah it is great like like there
are so many tech recruiters out there
right
and even more so in the uk markets
for sure so like what what did you have
to get really good at as a consultant
that you think really contributed to
being more consistent
that helped you stand out and achieve
your goals
i think it's a really basic skill and
another trait that i was going to
mention earlier about
a successful recruiter and it's it's
listening
so i think it's forgotten about a lot in
recruitment but
if you're a good listener and you can
really listen to your clients and your
candidates and
understand them fully then you're in the
best position
to deliver what the client wants and get
the candidate what they want
as well so i do really listen to people
and
what i made sure i tried to do as much
as possible was meet people face to face
get in front of them dedicate that time
to them and
the majority of the conversation them
talking
and me listening um
what was you listening for that you
think like that that helped you then
come up with the right solutions or
whatever like what what what were the
things you
were you like making sure that you
really listened to that helps you build
credibility and trust
just just understanding them asking them
open questions
um getting them to be open with me
as well i guess the the best
relationships is where
you can be open so if you can build that
rapport initially
they are more likely to be open with you
and
and show them that you are a real person
you you want the best for them
um so i i found that by building that
rapport
and making people feel comfortable then
they are more open to giving me the
information that i need to
help the client and help a candidate
okay love that i think it's a great
thing to highlight isn't it listen
because sometimes
especially early on you just want to you
wanna take that job brief you wanna do
you wanna
just get down to business don't you
you're so excited aren't you and that's
great
but if you're not listening you're never
gonna be successful
so spoken about listening one of the
most popular areas that people want to
know about and learn from people about
it is client development
yeah so what were some of the most
effective ways
as mel the consultant which obviously
i'm sure you're still announcing
involved with this but like
early on what what were the most
effective ways that
you found really helped you build your
client base
i just worked harder than than anybody
else
and i just really do enjoy what i do
and i would just give it a 110
and go the extra mile for them um
i know it sounds really basic but it was
just my my graft and my work ethic
that i guess impressed them and then
i recommended me to other people within
the business and it started to build out
my client base
okay so i all we always hear about and
i'm sure you've
helped your team with this the
importance of getting referrals and
recommendations
absolutely yeah and a lot of people say
look
most most all of our clients come from
word of mouth and all this right
yeah what have you found has been the
best way of doing that so yes delivering
but like if we're going really practical
here a lot of people want to know right
what what is actually the best way of
getting referrals so yes you have to do
a good job yes you have to deliver
you're not going to get referred if
you're [ __ ] that's that's that's that
yeah what have you found is the most
effective way of actually
generating a consistent flow of
referrals and recommendations
showing that your solutions focused as
well um
showing that you're not just an order
taker you're here to
to give them solutions and make a
difference um
i think that that can be forgotten about
as well that
we are recruitment consultants um
so consulting them providing solutions
and yeah she's just showing them you'll
make a difference
yeah well i had to learn early on and i
was my um
manager said to me like you need to you
need to not be
a yes man yes yeah yes
very true yeah that but that's that i
feel like that comes
when you build up some confidence and
yeah i know that right and
but i think you're completely right and
i think even more so in the last six
seven eight months if you haven't been
consultative and coming out of real
solutions and
i mean i don't know how how you would
have survived
yeah exactly it is it's about confidence
it's about being brave and
perhaps suggesting solutions that they
might not like to hear
but the end of the day they'll
appreciate it
okay so management is that something
that you wanted
do you know what initially because i'm
not i would guess
i guess when i say when i first started
out i didn't ever think i want to go
into management
i just wanted to make money and and
progress
um in terms of my financial earnings
but then when i first took on my trainee
my first training i did really enjoy it
and
i do still enjoy it now what did you
enjoy about it
i just enjoyed being able to really make
a difference to somebody's life so
recruitment can change your life and if
i can make someone good at this job
i know that it is genuinely gonna help
them have
a better life both inside and outside of
work
so is that what ended up being your
bigger motivation
yeah yeah i would say so but a lot about
seeing people
grow in their confidence as well i think
initially it it can be quite a difficult
job
but if you can help somebody perform
better but grow as a person and grow in
their confidence then that is
is really rewarding okay
so what did you end up growing so you
took on your first trainee
what did you end up growing that team
too then before you got to sort of head
of practice
i think that was around about seven
seven or eight that i was managing okay
yeah so let's just talk about that
transition for a second because i think
that's what
people find that the most difficult yes
what what did mel do to make sure that
you manage your time effectively that
meant that one you could
maintain your performance yeah and then
also
make sure that you're getting the best
out of your team you're helping build
their confidence they're improving
like how how did you how did you go
about what did the typical
male day look like or what does it look
like now what have you done to make sure
that you maximize your time because that
seems to be a real
sticking point for a lot of people that
transition
absolutely and i think it's crucial that
you create pillars
and what i mean by that is my more
experienced consultants in my team
can help me deliver the messages
and help with perhaps less experienced
consultants and trainees but
having those seniors and those lead
consultants that are
below me to really drive the team as
well
is is really really what's helped me
build my team out and i think sometimes
they can look up to them
because they're a little bit closer to
the level that they're at
rather than me who's been doing it for
eight years and so it's just good to
have different pillars i would say
to to help your time but also to
build people's confidence as well
interesting so when you say pillage yes
so it's not just completely reliant on
mail to
no absolutely not okay
but how do you communicate that to
someone that
like what's in it for that person like
how do you
like how do you get the p how did you
get the buying of do you get what i mean
becoming a pillar for
for male because i might think well
you're you're just going to benefit from
that
right like so how do you cultivate the
mindset of well actually that that's in
my interest to do that or how have you
what have you identified in people that
you've then sort of encouraged that
then they've then ended up being a great
pillar for you
yeah well this the phrase isn't that
delegate to develop so
i think for them it's going to develop
their career
so most well all the people within my
team do want to progress
so by giving them different
responsibilities
the way that i would sell it to them is
that that's going to help them
get to the next level and people are
going to look up to them
and they're going to want to be them and
so not just for their progression but
also being that
go-to person in the office that another
role model that we
can have that people can look up to okay
yeah so okay interesting so sort of
tapped into their
drivers and is that how you help them
progress and things like that
yeah because we regularly do like
pdps personal development plans and
one-to-ones and
understand people's why's and
what they want to get to next and how
they can progress so i always know
for each person within my team what
they're working towards so that helps me
manage them obviously but also when i am
delegating
using that knowledge to help them
want to do it if that makes sense yeah
because i've heard this a lot
how important is it i'm assuming this
might be something you've had to get
better at but how important is it to
know your
your individual team's wise so important
i would say it's it's crucial and the
wise can change as well
so i think it's important to have those
conversations fairly regularly
because people can change in terms of
what what's driving them what's
motivating them
when i first started it was just to pay
off all the debt from university
start um actually getting out of my
overdraft
and but now my why is a lot different so
yeah understanding that is is crucial i
think
and how often would you encourage and
what's worked for you from a management
perspective to
keep a pulse on that what was that
something that you do on a quarterly
basis
sit every six months or what when do you
try and get a check of that with people
i would say every every month if you can
do
more formally you would sit down every
quarter but
i like to try and check in with people
on a one-to-one every month
just to make sure i still understand
that that is what's motivating them um
because some people aren't as vocal as
others as well so
it's important to really address it with
each person
and how does that actually help you as a
leader get get the best out of these
people
you can remind them on the hard days of
of what it is that why they're here um
when they're having a really tough time
you can use that to really
bring them back and and motivate them to
to push forward
and like like obviously you've been on
your own journey on this and it does
change but
do you think it's gonna be big do you
think it's got to be bigger than money
yes yeah i would say
yeah because um for me what i've had to
work out myself
like i think this the slight sort of
change is like okay if you say
yeah you're not completely motivated by
money that's okay for me what helps me
with that because
i'd say i'm one of those people but for
me what i had to
have to work out is like what that money
will enable me to do yeah for me it's
like right so if i achieve
if i do 100 k's worth of revenue in my
in my first year of business
um i don't get excited about seeing that
100k number that that doesn't excite me
it's
what's attached to that right so it's
well if i achieve that that means that
i want to be able to take my girlfriend
to this place or it means i'm gonna be
able to support my
parents or this or whatever right so
that that's when you say it doesn't have
to be bigger
it has to be bigger than money i think
it's working out what's attached
what things yeah absolutely and a lot of
people will say oh i want to buy my
first house or i want to buy a car
and that's great but it's about breaking
it down for them well okay well how do
you how much do you want to save
each month how many placements do you
need to do to
to save that amount of money so making
it real to them and really breaking it
down and
even having a picture of the house that
they want on the desk just to keep
motivating them
yeah and i think that's it sounds really
basic but if you have like it's that
seems
such an effective way of making it
achievable is that breaking down the
targets
to what's your average deal placement to
okay well
how many cvs does that mean you have to
send out and how many interviews do you
want to look in right and makes it
really tangible
absolutely making it real is is really
important
so really keen so we're talking a bit
about sort of
now the manager here and and how you've
progressed
yeah what as you've built this team this
is
always been in like the permanent have
you changed teams or has it always been
in the same sort of world
permanent yeah okay cool so
i'd be interested to get your thoughts
on this so like for you what are like
the free
non-negotiables of your culture
that you think drive the performance of
your team
so like what are the the free
non-negotiables for the oscar for the
permanent division
within your culture that you think
really contribute to
you and your your team performing
mindset
collaboration and work ethic
really yes yeah collaboration
is key i think and so important and
something that
i really push on within the team for
people to share
what's working well because everybody's
got their different strengths
and for some reason not a lot of
recruiters like shouting about what
they've done well
because they think oh why would anybody
want to hear about that why would they
be interested but
i encourage people every single day if
they've had a win
let's tell the rest of the team about it
because we can all learn from each other
and i think that's one of the the main
reasons why
my team is consistently doing well and
continues to break records is because
we're constantly
looking at what's working adapting it
sharing it
and it's pushing us forward i really
like that
and i think part of that as well is like
it's very easy for
mel the recruiter that's been doing it
for eight years to think
that win well everyone must do it like
that do you know what i mean like
especially if you're experienced it's
very easy to go
just expect or assume that of course why
wouldn't you do it like that
right yeah so how do you
how how um how do you get people to
communicate that is that i don't know do
you have a what's that group and this
like guys
just just changed my email to this and
it's
really resonating with people
we do it in multiple ways so we we have
daily scrum so
in the morning in the afternoon and
towards the end of the day we'll have a
scrum
um and within that i'll get people to
share anything that's worked well
that will be from trainees to lead
consultants so
at every single level and we also have a
whatsapp group as well
we also obviously have emails that go
around regularly but
yeah as many ways as possible to share
what's working
love that and then how do you prevent
surely you must have sort of had to
combat
like this sort of just internal
competitiveness
because surely do you know what i mean
or is it is it very easy to manage that
because they're doing different
verticals or different spaces i just
feel like some people might be listening
go
yeah i'd really love to do that but jim
and henry they do go up against each
other
and and they're sort of covering the
same patch do you know what i mean i
don't know
about that no not really because we all
work
different verticals um so it does help
us
in the sense that nobody is directly
against
each other um so i've not had to come
up against that thankfully okay fair
enough
so you then obviously so you've been
growing your team and then so after that
you then got the head of so how many
people were you responsible for then
so at that time it was around about 12.
12 okay and then did that change much
when you got to associate director then
did the responsibilities change there or
what was the sort of differences
no it didn't really change that much it
was just to recognize the
the amount of people i was looking after
and within my team as well i had
seniors and leads building their own
team
so i was like the the grandma or the
great grandma
okay so why why have you
so like i think for me what what like
i'd be interested to get your thoughts
on like why
why has mel been able to get those
opportunities because a lot of people
may be in the same position as you are
and someone else
gets the promotion or whatever like why
why have you been able to
go from yeah team lead to head of
and not stop there like why why would
you put that down to
i'm just consistently persistent i don't
give up
um when i hit my target say i hit my
target halfway through the month if i
don't sit back and chill out i'm like
right okay
let's keep going let's keep pushing and
i like to push myself outside my comfort
zone
and yeah i know it sounds really basic
but
i do i don't switch off i just keep
going and i always want to get better at
what i'm doing
even where i'm at now and being director
there's still
things that i can get better at and
there's still things that i'm working
towards so
yeah just keep pushing for more i like
that
and when you say keep pushing for more
and you hit your target like how have
you communicated that
so who is your direct report andy then
or is it someone else or not
so yeah andy and matt who's the other
director as well
okay so the reason why i asked that is
because i i was having this conversation
with someone else the other day but
like how involved have you got those
guys in
your targets and basically sort of
agreeing like
hey if i do over exceed will that mean
this or like do you know what i mean how
have you
communicated that to the people sort of
above you that are the people that
ultimately can encourage the progression
and
and yeah decide on the progression
essentially like how involved have you
got them in your targets out of interest
very involved we've got a really open um
culture so andy and matt are there every
single day and we're having
conversations like this all the time
and they're definitely two of the
reasons why i am where i am because
they will push me that little bit more
um
and they won't kind of let me stay still
which is great
okay what's what's what have you found
most difficult
so far with mel the leader and and
managing these people and
and getting yeah managing even more
people like what have you what have you
had to overcome i would say time
management
and then you probably hear that a lot
but especially as your team grows
and especially because i'm still billing
as well
just having um what why have you
have you can't have you decided that
that you want to stay building
so i am going to be transitioning to
being more hands-off
um in the very near future but i've
always
felt that me doing it helps me
lead from the front and helps me manage
and motivate people
because they can see me doing it and i'm
in touch with
doing recruitment every single day so
when i'm telling them to do something
they know that it's coming from the
right place
because there can be sometimes that
friction can't they yeah but i do that
it's a bit of a cop out though isn't it
it's a bit of like well now look
you're not you're not on the phones like
i am yeah of course it
is so i can actually show them that i've
done it and
i guess they know that i wouldn't ever
tell them something to
to do something that i haven't done or
wouldn't do myself
yeah so let's let's break down this time
management then now because probably one
of the most popular questions that i
get encouraged to ask is like what did
mailed the 100k biller day look like
compared to what it looks now when
she's billing x or managing your
responsibilities all over do you know
what i mean so like
what what break down your day for me
like what what would like a great day
look like for you
what what time do you start what do you
make sure you have in there what are
your
negotiables for your day each day like
what does your day actually look like
that's
enabled you to maximize your time
being a leader and billings yeah so i
split my day into four so officially we
start work at half eight but
i usually start around half seven
quarter to eight
and so a bit of the morning person and
get up about quartz five in the morning
to do my workouts before work
um but yeah usually my day would start
at half past day
doing the the daily scrum with the team
so that's setting out
um targets and pledges for the day doing
a bit of the motivational
i guess um chat of where we're up to so
far in the month
again sharing anything that's worked
well the day before
um and then we'd we'd go into the day
from there so from about
ten to nine nine o'clock um back to our
desks and
then i would probably sit with my
trainee initially
um and make sure that she's properly set
up or she
he or she um and then i would split my
day into client development account
management and new business
okay what they're the next the next
stages the next parts of it
okay yeah so it can vary each day
um someday so some days half my day is
split
with dedicated to my team and the other
half would be
mel on her billings but we have this um
phrase which was taken from trevor
pinder who came in to do some training
with us about wearing a green hat
so when mel wears a green hat you know
that you can't distract her she's
focusing on her
her her billings and her desk and so
it's about being a little bit selfish as
well and not
wanting to answer every single question
that's coming to you at times you do
have to just dedicate
it to your own desk and make sure you're
you're managing it in the right way
so putting that stake in the ground and
going look guys if it is like a really
bad situation
you can but like i'm focusing yeah yeah
absolutely so what so what do you do
before clearly you're someone that's
quite organized
um some of you may know a lady called
amy still from memorial bonds
on and for her she really broke this
down really well and she said
what had what she had to make sure she
did and what really made a difference is
making sure that
when you do go into that part of your
day that you know exactly what you're
doing
like so how when do you prepare and what
do you
always always prepare the day the night
before
so when i'm i'm going into my day
it's not just saying right i'm going to
do new business today and
blindly call companies i know exactly
what companies i'm calling
who i need to speak to what the reason
for the call is
so i'm prepared a lot of it is about
planning and preparation to
make sure your your time is spent in the
best way and then most effectively and
you're not working till
nine ten o'clock at night because you
planned and you prepared for it
yeah okay yeah so that plan by it's
important isn't it
making sure that you know okay so how
much of a plan
because i think it's so easy for
recruiters to go i need new clients
new candidates and you probably hear
this all the time but like
how much of a strategy or have you ever
had a strategy or how have you
approached
and what's come out of conversations
recently is actually
like what are you doing to grow existing
accounts that could that could be
that could grow right so i don't know
what's been your journey or maybe
some of the the people in your team like
what what have you seen
work and do you have a plan and strategy
to actually
take an account that's typically
spending anywhere between 50 to 150k
with oscar
to making that the following year 250
quarter of a million
like 500k account like what i don't know
what how have you approached it
what's been going on there yeah i guess
so
for example for me i've always done
software development
and i think when you first start in
recruitment you can be quite
narrow-minded to
just speaking to the software
development manager because i want to
make placements for developers within
that team
but we cover so many different
disciplines across
oscar so within technology but also
within
sales as well so we've got
different consultants all work in
different areas so i think it's just
making a conscious effort to make sure
that you're reminding the company that
you work with that you can't just help
that hiring manager but you can help
other teams within the company and
really
giving them an insight into who oscar
attack are
as a business it might be that they've
got an office over in
austin or houston where we've got
offices as well
so really just having the bigger picture
in mind when you're speaking to these
people
and which initially people do struggle
with but
it's only going to benefit us obviously
if we can integrate into different
hiring managers and
if we can place within the sales team
also in the within the technology team
so yeah just thinking of the bigger
picture i guess
okay interesting so
from what you've seen and the people
you've worked with the people you've had
in your team in time like where do you
think most people
go wrong with client development because
it's definitely the area that
most people feel they need to develop
the most in
it's the area that people may find most
challenging at the beginning like where
where do you see recruiters typically go
wrong
they give up after the first i guess two
or three
attempts of contacting the client so
some of the most successful recruiters
in my team and
something that i've always done is being
persistent with it
and i don't mean being a pest but
consistently
following up with these people it's not
just a phone call it's an email it's a
linkedin
it's trying to just stand out to them
and following that up every single day
follow-ups yeah it's it's very basic
but it's something that's forgotten
about and it might be
the 20th follow-up you actually get
through to them
and this has come up again quite a few
times but i guess there's that fine line
of being a pest isn't there and
sometimes yeah
i mean i i had the nickname in the
office when i was in recruitment of
hisham the hounder
and i because i were i was i was i was
pretty
persistent i i was that person but i
think where i could have improved
looking back
was like i was confident if they did
pick up or i got hold of them that it
would be a good experience and like i'd
i'd be outside
where i could have improved and be a bit
more tactical is like and this is what
i'd be interested to get your thoughts
on is like
what do you try and do in those
follow-ups that might be a bit different
what i mean by that is instead of always
just trying to go hey we'd love to chat
and tell you about what we do here at
oscar tech or whatever like
are you leading with value and going hey
look i've just seen this article
before it might be interesting you know
what i mean like to what yeah what do
you try and do in these follow-ups to
make sure it's not always the same
message
so if you can make it personal to them
to say they've just won
an award or as you say they've written
an article about something
and you've picked that out and you've
said look i've listened to this that
you've done i found it really
interesting
be great to chat like you're not just
doing the basic
like can i send cvs to this job
you're trying to find something that's
going to stand out
um whether it be congratulating them on
the
recent promotion or as i said if the
business has won an award
just something a little bit different
that will show to them
that you're making an extra effort to
to get their attention yeah i like that
and then i i got this question for you
the other day from someone but like
and it can be yourself or someone out
someone else that you've seen but
what's been the the weirdest thing or
the most out of the box thing you
that you've done that's ended up getting
you that opportunity to get that client
meeting or
start working with a client i guess
something that we've done recently
um because obviously with the pandemic a
lot of people have been working remotely
so we've been doing um voice notes
on linkedin which has been
something that linkedin have introduced
the last couple of months so
notes have gone down quite well and when
you sat at home
recording them you do feel a bit strange
at times but
i guess that has um it's paid off for us
and it just shows that you're an actual
real person you can
put your personality into it and i've
had a lot of success from doing that
yeah and the good thing with those as
well is um they're only a minute long so
they're prevented from waffling
yeah exactly
okay so it's enough no you haven't got
like a chocolate bar
story or like some mad wacky story which
that that's that's what i was i was
looking for but voice notes on linkedin
that's super practical
um handwriting letters i've done that
before as well
just something a little bit different
and posting that to to clients so
you know the ones that you are you have
been hounding and you tried
everything you possibly can and ham
writing a letter
has worked quite well in the past even
if it's just to say
thank you for that i appreciate the
effort at least it's a response and
you've
another touch point yeah yeah absolutely
okay
so what i'd love to just talk a bit
about now before we finish is like sort
of
um a bit more about leadership and maybe
a bit more around sort of
how you've had to adapt or how you've
approached the the last sort of six to
eight months because i i think
i mean i i don't manage anyone and i
think that that must have been so
difficult to
sort of adapt and sort of communicate
the right things and be the leader
remotely
so one of the things this is one of the
the questions that i think is really
really interesting you've mentioned it a
couple of times about yourself and your
own journey
and other people but when you are
developing
people that are rookies or early on or
whatever point in their career like how
have you
like dealt with or helped recruiters
that
doubt themselves like how have you
really actually helped these people
um not doubt themselves without
themselves less
like actual advice around that reminding
them of the little wins
that i get in every single day i think a
lot of people
for the right reasons are looking at the
long term and
they're getting a bit down because
they've not got a new job in or they've
not got an interview today or
you know something that's that's quite
tangible that we're aiming for but
they're forgetting the little wins that
they've got
and so just reminding them of that and
reminding them that
if they keep doing that every single day
it is going to get them the result they
want
and making it real to them by saying
look this is what i
did and this is how that's helped me get
success
so i think those little wins every
single day
just championing them has really helped
people
and help make help make it more real and
build their confidence
yeah okay nice and um
what what has been your biggest
challenge now of the last
six eight months i know obviously it's a
bit there's been different stages to
this right yeah in terms of being
be in the office for a period and stuff
like that but like what what have you
what have you found most difficult as a
leader of yeah now 18
recruiters um obviously through that
period some of that might have been
completely remote like what what have
you found most difficult as a
as a billing leader yeah i think when
you're managing people remotely
it is difficult especially with those
that aren't
as as vocal so the ones that aren't
ringing you as much you tend to to worry
are they okay
because you can't see them so um it's
just making sure that i'm
spending my time wisely in terms of
communicating with them regularly
um because i will get some people on my
team that are
calling me more than others and i've got
to remember that
those that are still um that are not
getting in touch to
to follow up with them and making sure
that i'm making an effort to communicate
with with everybody
um and how just out of interest like how
um
how have you incentivized people
remotely i think this is normally the
holidays and all these types of things
you know what i mean how have you
i don't know how have you and how have
you been what have you
been doing to encourage people to or
give them the
something to really drive obviously i
know you know their why and stuff like
that but
just curious because there's people
gonna have good days and bad days right
so
i don't know have you had any
interesting incentives or have you done
anything that
has sort of you've seen a real
engagement from your team and had an
impact
um i guess we've done little things like
delivery vouchers
um amazon vouchers we've done like
cocktail
making classes and just getting
deliveries for people because there's
not really been much we can do
but just trying to make make the best of
it and
get people on on camera as well as much
as possible
to to try and do socials remotely and
just see people and interact i think if
you used to ask someone to do a zoom
quiz now they're oh my god i'd hate that
oh
no like once at
um but what i was going to say like how
just
again out of interest like i think one
of the the biggest
impacts on this will be sort of people's
mental health and and
so the mindset and i think even and more
so
like for for you guys right now in
manchester right i had um
a lady abby uh dunnon who has a
recruitment business that serves the
hospitality industry right and
yeah so but at the beginning of this
period in
in march or so it was more of like just
processing it like oh my god
i've got boris johnson on my telly
telling me i can't leave my house like
is this real
what is actually going on and then we've
been on this whole journey now where
we're sort of we know what could
potentially be around the corner
but you might build up some momentum you
might be like right this bit it's been
really nice it'll feel a bit more back
to normal and then
get hit with like right you're back in
tier three right so
i guess what i'm asking is like how have
you
become better or what have you tried to
do to make sure that you can actually
find out if your people are okay because
it
that's even more difficult for a screen
right so like how
how have you gone about how have you
been trying to really find out from your
people with
like how they're doing just constant
communication with them
even more so than when you're in the
office if that makes sense so
just really making sure i am i'm
checking
in with them regularly and it's not just
about work
it's and about like how's like what have
you done at the weekend like how is
everything
outside of work um it's more on a
personal level as well
and i think it has it's it's helped
people bond and it's helped me
bond more so with my team throughout
this time as strange as that sounds
we've not actually been together
but really just making sure that they
are okay and
it's not just about work that i'm
calling them about
yeah fair that that that makes sense
um and another like real practical thing
here now like how have you
so kpis
like what i'm assuming like you've had
to maybe adapt
on what you look at and sort of i don't
know
with the the sort of like used
background talking about sort of smaller
wins but
how have you had to approach like making
sure that because there's got to be that
line isn't there where you've got
you've got to keep on top of performance
and they're doing what they sort of need
to do
but you don't want them to make them
feel like you're just sort of pushing
them down
do you know what i mean so have you had
to change
what you what you typically measure that
could typically mean that they
achieve the goals that they need to like
how have you approached the metrics and
what you've been looking at as a leader
to make sure you're keeping
tabs on things and it should be
so we've we've been constantly looking
at what good looks like
and i think when the pandemic first
happened that that did change initially
but we've been lucky in in technology
that it's bounced back very
quickly so we're now back to
what we know good looks like in terms of
our outputs
before the pandemic um so we've not had
to change
too much it was just the initial um
i guess the phase when it when it did
happen and we all went into
lockdown that we had to revise our
expectations
um slightly but then just keep
kind of on top of that in terms of
making sure people are motivated but
we're not being
unrealistic with what we're expecting
based on the market
yeah yeah i think i think quite early on
i saw quite a lot of people talk about
made sure that the sort of metrics were
mainly around things that you could
control like the amount of
conversations you have and stuff like
that right absolutely um
just interesting on this one i've asked
it um once before and
i did a post about it i think um it's
just an interesting one like
what do you think is the most important
kpi or action that
for a recruiter that sort of contributes
to success
i would say decision makers spoken to
that you're having with decision makers
interesting
nice okay yeah um
so now what would be your advice for for
someone
two things firstly would be your advice
to someone that
might look at sort of your career and go
i'd love to get where
mel gets to i want to achieve that
director status what would
be your sort of could be top three
things or like what would be your
sort of top advice for recruiters
listening to this that want to
progress and get to that directed status
within their agency what would you say
to those people
my advice would be to be brave
if i could tell myself eight years ago
when i first started it would would be
to
to step outside your comfort zone to be
brave
too even if you don't feel like it some
days
just come in and want to win and give it
100
um because that ultimately
is going to get you to the top if you
you give it even when you don't feel
like it
fake it until you make it um but yeah
just be confident
be brave and don't doubt yourself
i like that and then the other thing
that i'd love to get your thoughts on is
like if i'm
if i'm sort of early on my sort of
leadership journey
like obviously you've sort of really
sort of grown into that and
like what what would your advice be for
sort of potential new billing managers
or
sort of recruiters that are on that
early path of becoming a leader and
being not just responsible for
themselves but responsible for
more people in their their teams you've
mentioned that time management is
something you really had to
brush up on and your biggest challenge
but what would your advice be for
new billing managers or people early on
on that sort of leadership journey
i would say feedback is really important
again that's a really basic one but i
think when you're becoming a manager
you're either really good at giving the
negative feedback or really good at
giving the positive feedback
and what i've learned is that you need
to be good at both
you need to remind people how good they
are in certain areas how well they're
doing so you need to give feedback when
they're doing well
or you also need to give feedback when
they're not doing so well and they need
to improve in certain areas so
make sure you are both carrot and stick
you're you're giving feedback from both
sides
yeah i like that and um before i ask you
this sort of five final questions
yeah i just had a just interested in
this one it was
one of the questions that andy sent me
and it was just um
how much you think you've changed as a
person since the
early 20 year old now out of uni
really absolutely massive yeah um
i think it's confidence more than
anything i remember when i first
interviewed with andy
and i had a glass of water on the table
and i was so nervous i had to hold my
glass of water with two hands
um but yeah now like for example on
friday i did a pitch to
a new company um in front of a boardroom
full of people so it's confidence and
if i didn't get into recruitment it
wouldn't have made me the confident
person i am now
yeah i think i think that's amazing and
i think i was talking to you about this
before before i asked you these
questions i think um definitely part of
that i was saying i had um
gabby trotter on who sort of said that
was sort of what she really had to build
on
confidence earlier and part of that
definitely was
um yeah a lack of female role models so
yes i know you're you're someone that's
um
yeah can be a great female role model
for people but i guess if i'm
listen right now and i'm a um young
ambitious
um lady that wants to do one recruitment
but yeah
may lack that confidence what would you
say to them
just believe in yourself and if you
haven't got a female role model in your
company at the moment
i didn't have a female role model i have
got great role models in andy and matt
but you can become that role model for
other people
so use that as your motivation to say
right if i can get there
then i can make sure we get other female
role models in the company
so just having that i guess that drive
to
become the female role model within your
business
so use that as the drive yeah i like
that that's what happened
really yeah yeah absolutely i wanted to
i wanted to get there and i wanted to be
that person that other females can
look up to and that's helped us at oscar
now have a
a really good split of of male and
female role models
i love that so i've got five questions
for you now okay
yeah we finished so these are sort of
quick five questions but you don't have
to answer them
in a quick way let me know what comes up
for you okay
so um the first question is
if you could change the industry the
recruitment industry what would you
improve
if you'd asked me this before the
pandemic
i would have said collaboration with
other businesses
in terms of recruitment leaders
collaborating together
and not being against each other i think
that has changed slightly
and got better since the the pandemic
has happened
and he does a lot with other recruitment
leaders and looks at
what we're all doing well and how we can
share that what i spoke about before in
terms of collaboration
but i would just say more of that more
of recruitment leaders
in different businesses working together
rather than being against each other
i love that what book have you read
that has had the biggest impact on you
good vibes good life
yes it's absolutely brilliant it's all
about the synopsis
positive mindset what you think you
create
and just believing in yourself it's
again what i just spoke about earlier
having that
belief in yourself not being positive
that you're
you're not acknowledging um negative
things that are happening but you're
looking at it in a positive light and
how you can
guess be a solutions person rather than
somebody that's
negative and dwelling on situations so
i'd recommend that book to anybody
i love that if you could write
a linkedin post that could be seen by
every single recruitment consultant
across the world
yeah what do you want it to say
[Music]
interesting i actually did one recently
that it's very very basic but it's
um it was something along the lines of
i'm eight years in recruitment and i'm
still excited to come to work every day
so aim to be excited so be excited to go
to work every day
yeah and i put that on linkedin and andy
or matt they didn't tell me to write
that
but i do like i am genuinely excited
about coming to work even
eight years in yeah okay
i love that what did you spend
your first biggest commission paycheck
on
oh what did i spend my first biggest
commission check on
well initially it was my overdraft and
my credit card
um but then i bought a pair of labootins
did you my third pair i've now got three
really i love that um
final question what what's what's the
ultimate goal
for your recruitment career
to inspire others and to be a role model
i love that mel it's been an absolute
pleasure
thank you very much really enjoyed it